with us today we have Professor hin
Mendelson welcome Professor men
Mendelson is the Kleiner Perkins
Coffield and buyers professor of
electronic business and commerce and
management at the Stanford Graduate
School of Business his work has been
published in many leading journals and
he's been a consultant to Leading High
technology companies stock exchanges
financial services companies management
consulting companies and Industrial
companies Professor mendleson what a
lineup That was thank you so much for
being with us today and we're really
looking forward to today's
session thank you very much Robin it's
great to be with with all of
you
um today we're going to
discuss business models and disrupt
option and the plan of the webinar is
first of all to talk about what is a
disruption it's a concept that people
talk a lot about but very often don't
Define so we'll Define what it is we'll
see how how it relates to the concept of
a business model and we'll then a go
into what is a business
model we'll put together a framework for
things about business models we'll apply
the framework we'll think about some of
the key tradeoffs in designing a
business
model we then talk about a number of
different types of business models with
a number of applications and we'll
discuss how some of these examples have
resulted in a response to
disruptions so that's the plan so let's
start with that plan so
basically what is the disruption is kind
of our first
question and essentially
disruption
is a change in technology in customer
preferences in competition or in
regulation that necessitates a major
business model change so that's how
business models and disruptions are are
related to one another so whenever we
have a big change that requires a big
change in our business model we call
this a
disruption and if you think about a
business model as a house A disruption
is like an earthquake that requires us
to redesign the house sometimes part of
the house sometimes we need to rebuild
the entire
house so so what so what is a business
model because when I Define disruption I
use the concept of a business model so
again if you go to the analogy of a
house before you build the house
hopefully what you want to have is a
blueprint that describes the
architectural structure of that
house a business model is a very high
level architectural structure that
describes the structure of a business so
it's essentially a theory or a blueprint
of the business itself in just like a
mathematical model or a high level
blueprint it is St ized it focuses on
the key elements of the business model
and the relationships among them it
doesn't describe everything it just goes
at a very high level the business model
concept is used both for startups where
it provides an organizing framework for
building the business model or for
established companies that are facing A
disruption and they need to rethink
their business model and redesign the
business model and to some extent go a
bit into uh startup mode so both of
these are cases where we really need to
think carefully about our business model
and as I said it's a little bit like a
the
architectural high level architectural
blueprint of a house and it has three
key points the first three key elements
the first element is the value creation
model that describes who are our
customers how we're going to create
value for these customers and how we're
going to deliver that value to
them so that focuses on the customer the
second room of that house is the profit
model that describes how we're going to
extract some of the value that we
create in the process of running the
business it describes the revenue model
the cost r structure and the key drivers
of profitability the roof of the house
house is the logic of the business model
which basically describes what our goal
is sometimes we put more emphasis on
profits sometimes we put more emphasis
on growth sometimes we have a nonprofit
so we have a totally different objective
we want to save the planet all of these
are goals
that drive the logic of the business and
the logic of the business basically
answers the question why do we think
that we're going to achieve that goal so
when we design a business model we think
about how we're going to create value we
think about how we're going to extract
some of that
value we think about the interaction
between these two elements and we think
about how that interaction is going to
help us achieve our objectives so these
are kind of the key things we think
about when we build a business model one
of the things that we need to keep in
mind mind is that there is typically
tension between the value creation model
and the profit
model and a that
tension is people tend to not focus on
it and it's actually pretty important to
think about it when we build the
business model because we need to
realize that some of the decisions that
we make that create more value may
actually hurt our
profit interesting example of that is
the example of Facebook so when Facebook
was
established um they kind of described
what they're trying to
do and a what so this is kind of this
picture is actually a picture that
appeared on the Facebook hoodie that
people had in the year 2010 so they
would wear a hoodie and inside that
hoodie they would have this picture that
describes the value creation model of
Facebook so the idea is that we want to
make the internet more open than
connected using essentially the stream
here which is the uh the news feed and
the social graph and the platform that
enables outside developers to tap into
our system so this is the way Facebook
described itself and importantly they
said you know our Val creation model is
really almost perfectly aligned with our
profit
model and in fact when Facebook was
first established at Harvard University
it's one of the few startups that
started at Harvard not at Stanford uh
what they did was they made sure that
they can actually make money before they
grow so basically they made sure that
each time they added the server in
another University they made sure
they're going to have enough advertising
Revenue to cover the cost of that server
so from their perspective they thought
about the value creation model and the
profit model
together and a one could argue that the
two elements of the business model are
very well aligned but of course over
time as it turned out there are some
cracks in that alignment and essentially
what happens is that a because Facebook
Facebook's profit model is based on
Advertising so Facebook funds itself
through advertising advertising Revenue
what happens is that they don't think
they have to think not only about their
users they need to think as carefully
and sometimes more carefully about the
paying customers who are the advertisers
so they have to design the business
model so that there will be a high level
of Engagement so that people will stay
engag with the with the platform so
people will come back to to Facebook and
indeed they've managed to keep a very
high level of Engagement over a very
long period of time because that was a
metric that they focused on but if you
want people to be engaged the question
is how do we do that and we measure all
kinds of metrics the drive engagement
and as it turns out content which is
more
polarizing content that makes people
angry content that a makes people agree
with more extreme V views tends to be
more engaging in that sense than content
which
is a little
more
friendly and the result of that is that
when you just apply the Facebook
Facebook algorithms what what you tend
to do is really
a
amplify some negative Trends so the
result of that is that actually to make
money to support the profit model what
we're going to do is actually adjust the
value creation model so that users will
not be as well off as they would be
without that profit model and the reason
is of course that the profit model is
driven by the
advertisers and the value creation model
is driven by the users so we really need
to satisfy the advertisers and that's
that's not the same as satisfying as
satisfying the
users so the result of that is tension
between the value creation model and the
profit model now if you think about kind
of so people say you know Mark
Zuckerberg is he an angel he's he's the
devil we need to to take that back and
kind of think about what is the business
model why are they doing that and in the
case of Facebook they have a very
effective business model from a
profitability point of view what you see
on this chart is a the average revenue
per you per user per quarter for
Facebook where the blue bars are
averages in the United States you can
see that in the fourth quarter which
which is the peak quarter Facebook is
making more than
$60 per user per
quarter so think about this they they
make if you think about Netflix Netflix
is making approximately in Revenue about
$48 per user per quarter so Facebook is
making an average on each user more
money than Netflix is making and Netflix
has to make all of these investments in
creating content then spend billions and
billions of dollars on new content all
the time and Facebook but by just
putting people together is able to
create much more money so basically
Facebook is executing a business model
that calls for satisfying the
advertisers because that's where the
revenue is coming from and it's not not
the only business model that can work
for content and interaction so compare
that to a company called
substack that where content providers
can publish their content and create a
direct connection with a their
users and in the case of a
substack you can see in this picture
their growth so is growing the growth
rate is very nice at least until the end
of 22 we don't have data following
2022 and the way it works then is that
you can subscribe to a content provider
and they can send you some content for
free and if you want you pay them
typically $5 a month or $10 a month and
they send you premium content only for
subscribers and substack is taking a
percentage of that Revenue so this is a
business model where there is a much
better alignment between what the value
creation model tells us to do for the
users in what the profit model tells us
to do for our profits there's very good
alignment because our paying customers
are exactly the users for whom we're
creating the value but if you look at
the numbers here so this is in thousands
so by the end of
2022 they manag to get 2 million paying
subscribers compared that to Facebook
that has three
billion users that generate Revenue so
you have to make make a choice when you
build your business model you can choose
between a Facebook business model free
to the users but less alignment or the
Sach business
model paying users great alignment but
the numbers are much smaller and what
Facebook is doing essentially is
selecting the free business
model and that's one of the things that
makes it more most profitable so when we
select our business business model we
need to think carefully about the
tradeoff between value creation and
profit and where we want to be and it's
up to us to make that decision some
companies start in one way and go to the
other as a result of disruption and a
good example of that is Netflix so
Netflix started as a company where you
rent
DVDs and a you pay subscription so just
like subst is subscription model and it
creates great alignment between the
users and the company because if the
user doesn't like the content they quit
so everything is driven by the value
that we create for the users and you can
see in this chart the growth of the
number of DVD subscribers that net net
Netflix had when it started was only in
the United States so by the end of 2010
the number grew to approximately 180
million subscribers which at the time
was considered a great
number now of course a late of the 20
the first of the first years of the 20th
century gradually we've seen an
increasing emphasis on streaming and
that presented a potential disruption
for Netflix and what you see in this
chart I expanded the time frame FR and
you can see on the left the the brown
bars represent the number of DVD
subscribers which picked in
2011 and starting in 2009 roughly
Netflix started providing to its users
also streaming content which initially
was provided for free and then became
paid content and you can you can see in
kind of the transition from an emphasis
on DVDs and an emphasis on streaming so
this is what A technology-driven
disruption looks like right so what we
see here is a big change in the business
model from one that's based on
distribution centers US postal office
service you know physical DVDs to one
that's based on a everything is digital
we start creating our own content and
you can see that the number of DVD
subscribers is going down
sharply and during that period of
disruption big business model change
what happened to Netflix was that it was
almost destroyed because the
transition from one model to the other
model was not smooth and to kind of at
the point where they decided to separate
the two
models they dramatically raised the
price of a that most of the users had to
pay and they lost a lot of users so it
took them a year or two to kind of
figure out how to stabilize the business
model they've managed to do that and you
can see the blue bars kind of rising
very
nicely and you can also see the green
bars they started as part of that
process once you have streaming
technology you can actually expand the
business model to other countries
initially to specific countries and then
to the rest of the
world he and this picture ends in
2019 right so Netflix became the
streaming giant the leader of the uh
streaming based business
model and a let's look at what happened
later so you can see this chart kind of
takes us from 2013 to the present and
you can see the number of users the
subscribers is growing very nicely but
then it's becoming flat it's actually
growing more than nicely during the
pandemic but then it flattens out and in
fact there was actually declin in the
number of subscribers in the United
States so at the end of 2022 Netflix
decided to change business model again
and to switch from a business model
that's based only on subscriptions to a
business model that mixes subscriptions
and advertising and as we've seen before
this has big implications for the way we
we think about the business because with
an Advertising based business model we
need to satisfy not only the subscribers
but also the advertisers today the
effect is small the revenue they have
from advertising 2022 is something like
half a billion dollars but it's expected
to increase quickly and at that point
they will face the same dilemas that
that we've talked about for for
Facebook let's talk briefly about the
uh let's talk briefly about the business
model development process how do we
develop a business model let's think
about you know going to space so in the
United
States kind of the agency that opened up
space to the world to at least in the
United States was
Nessa government essentially government
funded entity that developed the
technology and and kind of space
exploration and so on and you know a
slogan that was formed when they they
had problems with Apollo 13 was failure
is not an option so for Nessa whenever
they sent a satellite they kind of
worked very hard to make in advance that
everything will go right of course it
didn't always happen but the idea was we
are putting a lot of
effort to make sure that nothing will go
wrong because failure can be
catastrophic let's compare that to the
approach which is taken by by
SpaceX by the way you see here how much
money a NASA was getting I started this
in 2006 of course in the 60s and 70s
there was a lot of funding for Nessa to
the space missions that they had then
but I wanted to start in 2006 and the
reason is that I want to compare them to
SpaceX which got its initial F funding
in
2006 and of course
SpaceX has a very different
approach and the approach of
SpaceX is
that
failure is the only option it's not that
failure is not an option failure is the
only option and basically if you compare
NASA's funding to SpaceX funding what
you see on the black chart is from 2006
to this year the cumulative funding that
went to Nessa which is roughly about 20
billion dollar a year and what you see
in the green bars which is are hardly
seen here is the funding went to SpaceX
so you can see that SpaceX is used and
in 2006 you can't even see it in this
chart but it's a very small number but
you you see here that
SpaceX funding was only a fraction a
very small fraction of the funding of
Nessa but you could argue this chart is
unfair because some of the money that
came to SpaceX was not from people who
funded it but came from Nessa itself so
let's add to the Nessa numbers I'm sorry
to the SpaceX numbers the money that
they got from Nessa and you see it in
this chart so the green green bars are
funding for
SpaceX and the small you can hardly see
them the the brown additions to the
Chart are the amounts of money that went
from Nessa to SpaceX so you can see that
SpaceX you know a very lean
operation and of course they have a very
different approach their approach is
that uh failure is the only option we
fail and fail and fail and by failing we
create the information that enables us
to develop our product and our business
model until we
succeed and a a good example is their
most recent
major major
a a
launch and you see here the beginning of
the launch of a their their
current their current
product which is a Starship so Starship
is kind of the
space the
space the space so there's a rocket and
then there is the actual capsule and
that's the one that's going to go to
Mars by the way it's going to serve them
before they go to Mars to to sh ship a
lot of satellites to Earth and it has
I'm sorry to to orbit and it has a very
large number of a it can take a lot of
of those satellites so it dramatically
increases the profitability of the
company and in April of this year they
had the major launch kind of the first
major test launch of of
of of this a a
combination and you can see they started
and then it went out and essentially
um what you see here is what they call
Rapid unscheduled disassembly or
rod in short Rod means that it blew up
right so the the spaceship the whole
thing blew up and it's interesting to
see the reaction of SpaceX employees who
are kind of a
a following what happened and what you
see here they are kind of celebrating
they're cheering up and they're so happy
and you know the spaceship blew up why
are they so happy and in the same in the
same event you could actually see we
don't have it here Elon Mark he's
smiling he's happy and why are they
happy because the failure gave them a
lot of information that increases the
likelihood that their next launch will
be successful so the approach that space
is is taking is an approach that's based
on failing to learn and typically when
we develop a new business model we have
to assume that it's so new that we don't
really know for sure whether or not it
will be
successful and as a result of that we
need to plan for these failures as
learning events we need to iterate on
the business model test it out
systematically test element by element
of the business model and that's how we
create a viable business
model let's look at a a business model
types I call them archetypes there are
many types of business models in the
world but there are four types that
cover a significant percentage
of many of the business models that we
can actually see in
action and a I'm going to show it to you
by looking at the same industry same
industry you have multiple business
models and all of them can be
successful and a I'm going to use a the
the lodging industry and why did they
choose the lodging industry because
actually in the lodging industry you
have large chains like
Marriott which which combine many
different business models So within the
same company you can actually have
multiple business models and this each
brand of Marriot there are about 30
brands of Marriot is each of brands of
Marriott actually represents a totally
different business model so what they
have is basically a segmentation of the
market into multiple business models
which have multiple value creation
models that attract different types of
customers and have different profit
markets the first the first brand I want
to look at is the second one in this
picture is Rich
Carlton
and basically uh Rich
Carlton what you see here is the uh
website richz Carlton in Half Moon Bay
which is just a few miles from
Stanford and richz Carlton is a luxury
brand um and you know the the lowest
price room you can get during this
period here in Rich Caron is
$700 but actually it it goes up
dramatically so you can get a room for
$700 $800 $2,000
$4,000 and the question is why do people
pay $4,000 $2,000 for a room they
basically pay for used bed that's what
they're getting so are people willing to
pay so much the reason they're willing
to pay so much is really a key element
of the rich Caron business model which
was
invented about 70 years ago when they
started before they had computers and
they decided that what they're going to
do is base their business model on what
I call customer intimacy which means
that we deliver deliver the best
solutions to specific customers or
customer segments by tailoring our
products or services to satisfy unique
or highly targeted customer needs and
how do they do that so basically they
they did early on what most hotel chains
do today using computers which
is a to basically record the preferences
of their
customers and record the preferences of
their
customers and
a I'm looking here at the questions I
see these are technical questions I'm
not going to address
them
um yeah it's all technical questions but
if people have
questions uh
then then I'll try to address them if
they kind of fit in
um so the basic idea we record
information about our customers and we
use that information to give them
increasingly better quality of service
so for example historically the first
time you went to a rich
Carlton they would give you three types
of cookies and in the morning they would
watch which cookie did you
eat
and they would record which cookies you
ate so now they know which cookies you
like and the next time you go to Rich
Colton they give you just the cookies
that you like because now we know what
you like if you want to go to a certain
type of restaurant you ask you you ask
well how do I find a you know a Japanese
restaurant they record that and next
time you go to any risk Al on they say
well we have a great Japanese restaurant
in this city here it is if you rearrange
the room they will actually record how
you rearrange the room and they'll try
to match it next time you go there
unless it's a really unusual way to
rearrange a room so the idea is that we
collect information about our customers
and as a result of that we can give them
high quality
service as a result of the quality of
service the customers come back to
us when they come back they give us yet
more information so we can give them
even better service so but what happens
is that frequency drives information
which drives quality of service which
drives loyalty which drives frequency so
we have virtual cycle of customer
intimacy this is the logic of customer
intimacy that we see in many many
different types of business
models let me go to another a marot
business model actually the first one in
of the L luxury brand is called Brands
is called addition so addition is kind
of a design based
hotel which is an example of what I call
a a product or in this case service
leadership and basically it's a it's a
business model that was designed the
hotels are designed by a famous
designer and that Designer tries to make
them give you a unique experience
exquisite looking
hotel and the idea here is to impress
you with the quality of the hotel
itself you see here kind of they said
the world's hottest hotel brand so
that's kind of what product leadership
is about it's kind of interesting when
the designer was asked what is so
special about addition why why do we
need to pay so much for it he said what
what distinguishes Apple phones from
everybody else you can't quite put your
finger on it but you're in a special
place right so a little bit like the
apple of hotels an apple of course is
another example of a product
leadership and definition if we go to
the definition of product
leadership
uh we create value for customers by
generating a stream of products or
service Innovation so it's the
innovation of the service that drives
customers to us the next kind of a
archetype is one that I call operational
EX
where we deliver a standard product or
service that meets our customers needs
at a low cost or it provides Superior
functional performance and in the case
of Marriott this is done by their
Fairfield brand so the ffi brand the
idea here is that it's it's a very
functional hotel but the idea is that we
give you functionality and low cost and
we achieve that through standardization
so there's a standard template
essentially that's used to design the
hotel the hotels don't have a you know
uh the the the human based customer
services minimal you can buy thing
things at the vending machine there is
standard
breakfast buffet that you can get it's
reliable clean
functional low
price the idea is if you if that's what
you're looking for furfield is for you
and what you can see here that what they
advertise is the beauty of Simplicity
it's simple it's functional it does the
job at low cost and standardization is a
key feature that enables us to do
that um the
fourth
archetype that I want to talk about is
value chain
coordination where we create value by
coordin inating different elements of
the value chain so we have different
components of the value chain and what
we do is coordinate them and the
simplest example of that there are many
examples but I'm going to go with the
simplest
one which is a Airbnb so in the case of
Airbnb it's a Marketplace so a
Marketplace is the simplest form of
value chain
coordination and of course
Airbnb does not not own the properties
it simply coordinates the value chain it
matches hosts and guests and enables
them to
uh to work enables the hosts to to
provide spare space that they have or
space that they bought in some cases
where they have a professional host to
the guest and it enables the guest to to
get a
the type of
space that they're looking for as an
alternative to a hotel and if we kind of
think about in the case of
Airbnb how do they create value so they
because the Airbnb because it
coordinates hor and gas it really has
two types of customers and it needs to
satisfy both of them to work to satisfy
the host what they do is basically the
host get get extra revenue from
resources that otherwise would stay
idle so the value proposition for the
host is
clear the value proposition for the
guest varies so if you look at the
results of
surveys of why people go to stay at
Airbnb the number one reason they do it
is less expensive comp compared to a
comparable hotel room it's not always
less expensive s bnbs are very very
expensive but on average they're about
30% less expensive than a comparable
hotel room and that's what attracts most
people to Airbnb the second factor is
location so hotels by their economics
requires them to be close to Conference
Centers places where lots of people stay
and the hotel itself is a building that
accommodates you know hundreds sometimes
more people so it's a result of that
they're concentrated in specific parts
of a city and Airbnb is spread
throughout the city wherever people have
space so as a result of that if you look
for a specific location which is not a
conference center not a central
location uh what will happen is that you
could you're much more likely to find
that location on
Airbnb than on a
in a hotel and that's an advantage that
a lot of people uh prefer then the
experience if it's a great experience
sometimes the host helps you shows you
the city around and so on and so forth
easy to use sometimes you you want to
have your own kitchen you want to stay
in the house you come with the family
uniqueness of the units so all of these
are factors that the business model
enables you to do when we think about
the uniqueness of the units Airbnb is
increasingly emphasizing
that you can find all kinds of spaces on
Airbnb which are unlikely to to be
available in a hotel and you can even
find an igloo on Airbnb there in this
list there are 11 igloos that I
identified and about half of them have
Wi-Fi if you're interested and one of
the key advantages of the value change
coordination business model compared to
a standard hotel is that it's much more
scalable because you don't have physical
resources Airbnb doesn't have to own
these
properties so when you get started this
is a problem that you need to address
and in the course in the online course
we actually spend some time thinking
about how to address that problem so you
can see early on rbnb is increasing but
of course marot is much much bigger in
terms of the amount of money that people
pay to stay there in the aggregate but
but by
2017 Airbnb matched a
Marriot and by 2019 it exceeded marot by
far right because of the advantages of
its business model and it's interesting
to actually look at the effect of A
disruption on the operation of that
business model and the obvious
disruption that happened following
2019 was coid
19 right so Co 19 caused a major
disruption to the travel
industry and it affected Nega negatively
both Marriott and a Airbnb and you can
see here
2020 the gross bookings or on Airbnb
fall sharply the gross bookings on
Marriotts fall sharply if you compare
that to what happened in the industry at
large you can see that it was even worse
for the industry at large in terms of
the number of people that went to
hotels but the interesting thing is that
Airbnb is recovering much much faster
than Marriot and the reason is that it
has a much more resilient business
business model during coid 19 itself
during the disruption Airbnb was able to
to switch the type of space that was
available from Central City location
to to other types of locations because
basically Airbnb doesn't have to build
those spaces it's just that you have
different types of hosts that satisfy
demand that evolves as a result of
disruption the case of marott of course
they can't instantaneously build a new
hotel where people want to go so the
result of that they have to lay off
people they can't
respond and you can see that following
the disruption so hopefully coid 19 is
over by
now so you can see Airbnb going up very
very quickly and Marriott and the rest
of the industry recovering but much more
slowly because they have to hire people
they have to uh to to train them it's
not that easy to shift the types of
hotels that you want to have so it's a
much much slower and more painful
process and again that's reflected in
the economics of Airbnb you can see here
the number of nights booked or on Airbnb
in the blue line and the gross booking
value in Airbnb on the brown line of
course there's a lot of seasonality so
you can see it going up and down within
each year but the general trend is way
up much more than actually it it
continues to increase faster than it did
before before the
disruption as a result of
having a pretty good business model
which is the value chain coordination
business
model and so this is an example of
how previously we talked about the
technology disruption here we have an
example of how a disruptive event in
this case coid 19 affects the business
model and Airbnb has not only responded
to coid 19 but is now changing its
business model to a business model that
focuses much more on people who want to
who kind of where who want to to kind of
work from anywhere so work from home is
a phenomenon that's decreasing but it's
not going down to zero more and more
people work from many many more
different locations and Airbnb is
adjusting its business model to
accommodate that and get reflected in
their financials again because it's a
value chain coordination business model
it can do it much more effectively than
a more traditional business
models let's look at another example of
how uh technology changes the business
model and I look at another a value
chain coordination business model which
is called be my eyes so be my eyes
essentially it's a network
which has a users and the users are
people who are blind or are vision
impaired and basically they have an app
on their
phone and about they have today they
have about half a million people using
it in that way so very large number of
people all over the world and on the
other side of the network are a
volunteers who help them so if I'm blind
and I want to kind of see what shirt I'm
wearing I can point my phone camera to
to the to the shirt that I'm looking at
and I'll click on the app and that will
send the
image to a person who volunteered to
help one of the seven million people and
that person will will see the shirt and
will tell me on the phone you know this
is a shirt with is a striped shirt with
blue stripes and white stripes is that
the shirt you want
and I can say okay I actually want
another shirt and I point my phone and
so on so it's a value chain coordination
business model or a Marketplace which
has on one side vision impaired people
on the other side volunteers
that use the person's phone as their
eyes and they just tell them here is
here is here is what it is now what is
the technology disruption so technology
disruption in the this case is a large
language models or Chad
GPT so the way it works today still
experimental they call it be my AI
instead of be my eyes and the way that
works is well I want to wear that shirt
I point my camera at the shirt and it
takes the image of the shirt but instead
of going to a
volunteer it's going
to
open AI CAD GPT which looks at the image
and interprets it and instead of a
person saying it it's the large language
model that tells me on the phone you
know this is a shirt it has these
Stripes these Stripes so you don't need
the 7 million people now of course you
still need them because the large
language model is not
perfect but what happens you can see
here
you kind of Point your camera you get
the
reply and if you want you can ask a
volunteer because sometimes not clear
sometimes not accurate you can still ask
for a volunteer but what will happen
over time is as the application learns
more and more it will be increasingly
more accurate so the number of
volunteers that you will need will de
decline gradually over time and today
the kind of manual application with
volunteers is going to
uh is going to
uh to decline because it can be done
automatically so it's a total change in
the business model that's driven by a
change in technology of course AI
technology is affecting many other
companies and since we talked about
Facebook it's kind of interesting to
talk about Facebook in that context so
Facebook has made great strides through
the use of AI and through the use of
large language
models and a one of the kind of
disruptions that Facebook has faced was
disruption from Apple where Apple has
changed its
privacy policies so that they don't
automatically share app data with
Facebook which creates a big problem for
Facebook and people have said you know
Facebook it's it's really going to be
pretty disruptive to Facebook because
they the most of the user use it on the
phone and they lose that phone data what
are they going to do and indeed a
Facebook for a period of time has had a
hard time actually adjusting to that
change but it developed AI systems to
actually use it own data and data it has
available to it much more
effectively and as a result of that not
only have they been able to respond to
that change from Apple they've been able
to do better and in fact a few days ago
they actually announced their results
for the third quarter of
2023 so they had $34 billion of Revenue
which is like four times
Netflix and it was 23% higher than a
year
ago and it did all of that after laying
off 22,000 employees so they managed to
do that by using
Ai and data that they had access to to
do actually better that they could do
with the data that they got directly
from Apple's operating system
iOS the other thing they've done is of
course reduce their cost Dr atically by
both traditional means which are layoffs
that we talked about in using AI tools
to improve their own internal
productivity so basically uh you know we
can we can when we reduce cost in
traditional ways the effect is usually
not permanent it's a temporary effect
because over a few years what happens
everything comes back to the way it used
to be but when we reduce cost through
the use of technology in this case the
use of
AI these effects are permanent because
the technology is there to help us and
in the case of Facebook the effect was
dramatic so the combined effect of the
layoffs and the use of AI was that
expenses a percent of Revenue declined
from 80% of Revenue a year ago to 59% of
Revenue in the last quarter and their
profit almost tripled from last year
from $4.4 billion to 11.6 billion right
and they're continuing to use AI to
support their advertisers remember their
kind of main paying customers are
advertisers so they use generative
AI their large language
model to actually help first of all to
help so they have a system called
Advantage Plus it helps advertisers do
better matching for their ads but now
they're going a step further and help
them actually create the ad so what
happens here is that
a they use
technology to actually improve their
business model and respond in this case
in a positive way to a technology
disruption let me look we have a few
questions here so let me look at the
questions so there's a question about
Airbnb whether coid was A disruption so
by our definition coid was definitely a
disruption for airbnb's business model
because it was a big exogenous external
event that forced them to change their
business model so they didn't change
fundamentally what they do but they made
big changes in their business model so
it's certainly an example of disruption
for
bbnb so there's a question you have
mentioned that you will describe four
business model archetypes will you
summarize these later
so later maybe now so we can go back and
summarize them again so basically we
introduce them through the examples but
this slide summarize all fours the first
one is customer
intimacy where we deliver best solutions
to specific customer segments through
the use of customer data product service
leadership where we
innovate products or
Services operational excellence where we
reduce cost or increase functionality
for product or service homogeneously for
a large number of customers in value
chain coordination which is what we've
seen in the case of
Airbnb and B my eyes where what we do is
we coordinate elements of the value
chain in a special case of that is a
Marketplace so the question I have here
is how has SpaceX develop its business
model
has it been the same from the
start so I think that
fundamentally a SpaceX business model
has been based on the idea and we didn't
have time to talk about it but since we
have the question I'm going to go into
it so the basic idea of the SpaceX
business model is to build reusable
Rockets and the idea is that if you want
to be able to go to Mars and do it in in
a systematic way you can't do it if you
can use your Rockets only once because
that would be like developing you know
jet service between a San Francisco and
New York City where you can use the
plane only once I mean just economically
not viable so the basic idea was to
develop a solution where the Rockets are
reusable initially of course the Rockets
were not reusable so they continue to
iterate iterate iterate drive cost down
create reusable
Rockets and the business model has
evolved from that to okay so how do we
use these reusable Rockets then they
added to it a very important element
which is stalling which is when we send
out these Rockets we have customers that
pay us to ship to ship payload space but
you know we can always fill them up with
our on pay payload which are these
satellites that going to be in space and
provide a provide internet service to
people who do not otherwise have good
internet service and there are lots of
them lots of examples we w't go into
them so SpaceX again we've seen a
gradual evolution of the business
model so the question here is Facebook a
value chain coordination business model
absolutely Facebook is primarily a value
chain coordination based business model
which coordinates first of all
interactions between users and other
users and between users and content
providers and between users and
advertisers so it's a multi it's a very
complex value chain coordination
business
model but it's so this but it's
certainly a good example of that
business
model
um
the question is are these business model
Pro archetypes exhaustive no they're not
there are many business models that
combine these and there are business
models that outside this list of force
they're not exhaustive but they
represent a large enough percentage of
business models that starting from these
give us a good start so when you look at
the business model you say okay this
looks to me like the operational
excellence but they do also this and
they do also this so it helps us get
start started when we think about the
business model but it's certainly not
exhausted and with that I think I
covered the
questions in the Q&A so in
summary so what have we done we have
looked first of all at what is a
disruption
we we have looked what is a disruption
and we we defined it and we relate it to
the concept of a business bus model then
what we've done is as the question what
is a business model and how is it
structured and we've said you know you
you have to think about it like the arch
high level architecture of a house the
value creation model The Profit model
and logic which explains why it's going
to work and we've seen in a few examples
how this works and we've talked about
the tension between the value creation
model and the profit model and we've
seen that in the case of Facebook we've
looked at how that's a kind of solve but
in a way that creates much less Revenue
in the case of sub and we looked at the
Netflix disruptions where they gradually
changed their business models from DVD
to streaming and then from streaming
subscription only to streaming with
advertising which is what they're doing
now we then looked at the four business
model archetypes that we've reviewed
three minutes ago so I want to review
them
again and then we looked at a few
examples of how
technology and how external events kind
of force us to change the business model
so these are disruptions that Force us
to change the business model and how
companies like Airbnb and Facebook have
actually responded and have changed
their business models so this is exactly
11 A.M so I think we managed to cover
everything as well as all the questions
that we had so we've been very
productive today we've done we covered a
lot of ground there's a lot of detail we
could go into in the course
itself uh so thank you very much for
participating in the webinar and for
asking great
questions and if this is still morning
for you have a great day if this is
evening have a great evening and night
thank you thanks so much professor
professor Mendelson and everyone for
being here you and all your questions
and all your interactions what make
these sessions so special um we had
someone asked will the slides or
recording be available the recording
will be available and the slides will be
in the recording so you can view the
slides just how they were presented um
and so that will be to you within one
week if you enjoyed what Professor
Mendelson had to say today you might
enjoy our business model Innovation
course which is linked in your dashboard
and you can find it on Stanford online
so you can join us there for an online
course Professor Mendon thanks so much
it is morning where we are so I hope you
have a great rest of the day and
everyone else we're signing off thanks
so much
bye-bye